I was on the David Pakman show reddit
discussion forum this morning a david
pakman.com slash reddit thought I would
point out some interesting conversations
that are taking place to you hoping that
you will join the discussion there let's
start with a post about Mike Pence being
a better than Donald Trump because he is
medically sane and functioning and more
competent than Donald Trump and a whole
conversation started about if it were
pens instead of Trump who was ultimately
leading the country what would be the
pros and cons very very good
conversation going on there also this
morning on the reddit discussion forum a
discussion about Oliver Stone's new
multi-part interview conducted over
several years with Russian leader
Vladimir Putin and I saw a preview of
that pad it looks fascinating Oliver
Stone driving around with Vladimir Putin
and I have not seen it yet it's on I
think show time I don't get Showtime so
I'm enough to figure out how to watch
that but it looks very very interested
it looks as if Oliver Stone gave an
interview about the interview he had
with Valerie Putin on little bear with
Stephen Colbert
that's exactly right a vague Stephen
Colbert guy well there you go that is a
that's a will note that for the future
and now we know that you're a big fan
are you a Jimmy Fallon guy I don't
really watch any of those children I'm
not uh played enough although I know I
could watch it later the next day
whatever okay already also on our rent
discussion forum why is there little
talk about the social conservatism
within the black community a very
interesting conversation about something
that I have talked about before social
conservatism in the black community
interesting discussion from our reddit
discussion forum people angry that Pat
downplayed resistance to Donald Trump
from the UK Pat said that there was a
petition which garnered 600,000
signatures to keep Trump from coming to
the UK in reality that petition garnered
1.8 million signatures so that you were
wrong but that only made your point
stronger right no I don't think I was
wrong because it did get six hundred
thousand signatures it just got way more
than that yeah okay well I by a factor
of three you weren't wrong you were only
talking about the first six hundred
thousand Dodgers and lastly from the
reddit discussion forum
another one of these odd still images of
me during YouTube live streams and I
can't really describe it so if you're
listening to me you're just going to
have to check out the the video clip not
safe for work it's not safe for work
that's for sure
david pakman.com slash read it please
visit our reddit discussion forum there
are now nearly 4,000 of our viewers and
listeners Pat who are participating in
discussions on the reddit discussion
forum and for that I think we can all be
glad yeah all right
that's glad Pat seems entertained by
something that's going on I don't really
know what let's talk about that later ok